لقد شاركت في نشاط إرهابي ،
إنها جملة قصيرة يمكن أن ينتهي بها الأمر إلى
أن تكون حكماً بالإعدام ،
كيف جعلك ذلك تشعر أنه أذهلني
كيف يمكنهم أن يقولوا هذا فقط
هذا كان يجب أن تخبرني
أنك لا تستحق ذلك  العيش
في هذا البلد العظيم زلمان يازي أو زي
كما هو معروف عمل كمترجم أفغاني
للجيش الأمريكي لمدة
عامين تقريبًا
بدءًا من عام 2007 ووصل إلى الولايات المتحدة
في عام 2014
ليكون منزلًا لنفسه في ولاية أيوا ،
أريد فقط أن أكون على قيد الحياة
ولكن  بدأت قصته في وقت مبكر جدًا عندما
كان يبلغ من العمر 33 عامًا تسعة أعوام فقط
، ويقول إنه هو وأطفال آخرين
أجبرهم طالبان
على إيقاف دراجاتهم النارية
عند منزلنا
وكان هناك خمسة منا وقال كل
واحد منكم ذاهب  إلى المنزل وإحضار
قطعة من الخبز
وإلا سنحرق هذا المنزل
وسنفعل ذلك
وكنت خائفًا من أنني كنت أعتقد
أنني بطل ، لقد قمت بحماية عائلتي
ولم يكن الخبز أكبر من حجم
الهاتف المحمول
الذي أخبرته زي تلك القصة أثناء  له
مقابلة اللجوء مع المسؤولين
الأمريكيين والآن تقول الولايات المتحدة إنه
شارك في
نشاط
إرهابي.  في مقابلة ، أرسلته وزارة الأمن الداخلي
إليه هذه الوثيقة قائلاً إن هذا
ليس رفضًا لطلب اللجوء الخاص
بك ولكن طلب اللجوء الخاص بك قد تمت
إحالته إلى قاضي الهجرة
للفصل في
إجراءات الإبعاد
وسيقوم قاضي الهجرة بتقييم طلب اللجوء الخاص بك
بشكل مستقل
وليس مطلوبًا اتباعه  تقييم
المواطن الأمريكي وخدمات الهجرة
بأن يازي قد شارك في نشاط إرهابي ،
ما يفعلونه هو قول
بدلاً من ذلك بدلاً من تقرير ما إذا
كنت تستوفي جميع المتطلبات
القانونية للجوء أم لا ، سنقول
إنك لم تكن مؤهلاً للدخول
البلد في المركز
الأول في أفغانستان يقول زي إن طالبان
لا تزال تهدد عائلته
لقد قتلوا عمه لم أستطع رؤية
تلك الصورة ،
لقد كانت دائمًا صدمة بالنسبة لي الآن
يخشى أنه قد يواجه نفس المصير
إذا قامت إدارة بايدن بترحيله
إلى أفغانستان من
قبل الحكومة الأمريكية.
تم وضع علامة على
الجاسوس الأمريكي هل
أنا إنسان أيضًا أريد أن أكون على قيد الحياة إذا
كنت جالسًا مقابل الرئيس
بايدن الآن
ماذا ستقول له أنت
القائد وقد تم
الوعد ولكن يجب الوفاء بالوعود
الآن عندما نكون
سألونا خدمات المواطنة والهجرة عن قضية نيازي ، وأخبرونا
أنها سرية ولا
يناقشون ما بداخل
تلك الطلبات المضي قدمًا ،
وينتظر نيازي موعدًا للمحكمة مع قاضي الهجرة ،
لكن محاميه يقول إنه حتى إذا
خسروا ، فسوف يستأنفون
لأنهم  يعتقدون أن حياته تساوي
أكثر من قطعة خبز